okay welcome back
let's continue uh so this is our sixth
lecture
the topics for today are the exponential
family um
it's a it's a family of probability
distributions and
the generalized uh linear models are
glms
the two topics are kind of tightly
coupled so we covered them uh in the
same lecture
and before we get started a quick recap
to kind of
see the motivation for exponential
families and glm
so we have seen two two models so far a
regression model and a classification
model
and they were linear regression and
logistic regression
right and for both the linear regression
and the logistic regression we saw their
probabilistic interpretations
and for the linear regression the
assumption that we made was y given x is
sampled from a normal distribution with
mean theta transpose x
and some variance sigma square um
it it did not matter what sigma square
was and
um and and and that's fine
in the case of classification y given x
was sampled from a bernoulli
distribution
whose parameter was 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus theta transpose x right
and this was also
we call this g of
z equals 1 over 1 plus e to the minus
z and g of theta transpose
x becomes the ah
becomes a parameter of the bernoulli
distribution
right and then we had a smaller side ah
mostly a digression in terms of what
we're going to cover today but
you know this is going to be useful next
week
think of functions as points in an
infinite dimensional
functional space and you kind of get a
one-to-one
mapping between the domain of the
function and the axes of the uh
functional space
anyway so this is not relevant for today
but you know just kind of keep this in
the back of your mind
so we're going to continue along the
lines of
of the probabilistic interpretations
and we're going to cover generalized
linear models so
off the bat we we see a few things that
are common between these two
all right first of all we're modeling y
given x in both the cases
right the difference is that in one case
y is real valued
and in the other case y is binary valued
zero and one
and the the data type of
why whether it is you know a real valued
or or
a discrete binary value informed our
choice
of the distribution that we are going to
that we used
right uh it doesn't make sense to define
a bernoulli or a bernoulli over real
value similarly it doesn't make sense to
define
a normal distribution on uh discrete
values so the choice of
the data type of the y variable
inform the choice of the distribution
that we used
the other thing that we see in both both
of these
is the occurrence of
theta transpose x right
we have a theta transpose x here and we
have a theta transpose x here
right and
these two seem to be you know somewhat
somewhat superficial similarities
but what we will see or what we will see
today is that there's actually a much
much deeper and richer theory that kind
of unifies
these two and a lot more different kinds
of models under a common umbrella
right so and and that's called the uh
that's called the glm or the generalized
linear models we call it linear because
you know theta transpose x is linear
right and uh we call it generalized
because we generalize not just to
you know two types of data types of y
but
you know for for more general kinds of
ah y in general right okay so let us get
started with
exponential families
use a different pen
exponential family so the
exponential family can be written in the
form
so this is the probability density
pdf or
pmf so an exponential family
distribution
is a probability distribution whose
density has the form
p of y parameterized by eta
equals b of y
eta transpose
t of y minus
a of eta
right this this this is a cryptically
cake expression let's
add some color to this so the data that
we are
on which
probability is defined let us call it y
y y
all right and the parameter
of such a distribution
call it
eta eta
eta right so this is the greek
letter eta and if you're using latex
you use e t a
eta to get that symbol um
it kind of looks like n but it's just
normal data so
the parameter of the distribution is eta
and the support of the distribution that
is y
now we call it y um and not x
because it's a hint we are trying to
model the output of our models
with exponential families so um
so the probability density of y
parameterized by eta is given by this
expression
right and there are kind of three
functions over here so we have
b of y and
this is purely a function of y and
it's generally called the base measure
right and we have
t of y this is called the sufficient
statistic
and we have a of eta
eta is called the log partition function
right so um a few observations
the base measure or the function b
is purely a function of y only
and it has no eta terms in it
right and similarly the log partition
function
is purely a function of eta and it has
no y in it
right and similarly t of y is
is um is again a function of
of of y alone and for pretty much
you know uh most of this course and you
know
most commonly t of y will just be equal
to y
think of it as the identity function but
uh
for for most of the cases t of y will
just be y
and why are these called uh
um the these particular names so
one way to think of it is
the way an exponential family can be
constructed
is by starting with some base measure b
of y
right assume it is some probability
density and come up with
a new new distribution
whose density
is
right so what is happening here we have
some base measure eta
and we we can define a new
distribution whose density is
proportional to
the density of the base measure times
the
exponent of the parameter times times
the data
to make the simple let's let's now
consider
a scalar case and where the base measure
is and now
because it's a probability density
measure if we
normalize this we will have to
normalize this p of y
eta is equal to b of
y times e of minus theta
y over the integral of this with respect
to y
right integrate out y p
of y times e f minus
eta y
d y right does it make sense so we are
just defining a new
new probability distribution whose
density is is defined by
the you know some base probability
measure y
times the exponent of you know a
parameter times uh
e of y right and then we just
renormalize it
and this is also um in in in some
literature this is called
exponential tilting
right and now ah what is this this is v
of y times e f minus
beta transpose y ah
and this is just the expectation of
expectation of e to the minus
eta transpose y right
does that make sense this is just the
definition so this is the the the
density and this is some function and
you're integrating out so this is the
expectation
and this also happens to be called the
anybody
it's a log partition function ah but
just this form alone
is also called the moment generating
function right in
in um but that's not um
that's not relevant to to our uh
our study here so we can just call the
sum function of
you know let's call it capital a of eta
because you're integrating out y
the only variable here is eta
and this comes in the form p of y
times e of minus
eta transpose y
so ah i flip the sign here this
right x plus y minus log
a of eta
yeah so the question is should you know
uh should b
of y uh satisfy the probability the the
properties of a probability distribution
function
in this form it need not because you
know
um there could be some common constant
that get
cancelled between the two uh so here you
can actually think of it as some
b prime b prime b prime you know
and you know b prime and after you come
cancel the common constants you end up
with the b of y
but the the the main idea you want to
think of here is to get an exponential
family distribution
you start with some base measure b
do an element wise multiplication at
each term with a e of a you know you
introduce a new parameter
and ah multiplied by
exponent of that parameter times y and
then just
normalize it and once you normalize it
what you get is the kind of the
it's called the exponentially tilted
version of v of y
and that will be an ex a member of the
exponential family
right that's one way to think of how
exponential family distributions are
constructed and kind of gives you a
motivation of why it's called the base
measure so this is this also called like
the pre-tilted measure
and once you perform this process called
tilting you get a member
ah a distribution in the exponential
function
right all right so that's that's just
aside that's just
some motivation for why the names
you call this the base measure and the
partition function
is another common name for a normalizing
constant
right i think that term comes from
statistical physics where you use a
normalizing constants are called
partition functions
and because this is a normalizing
constant
and when you take it up here you know
you take
because the exponent this becomes a log
of a normalizing constant
and this is called a of eta
and therefore it is called the log
partition function
right that's that's ah that's just some
intuitions for
you know why the names base measure and
log partition function
uh why those names uh came into picture
but you know
um everything inside this box is is not
really uh relevant for
uh our study as such all right
so and and the claim is that a lot of
probability distributions
that we encounter for example the
bernoulli distribution
or the uh gaussian distribution the
normal distribution
and many more they're all part of the
exponential family
it means you can express these
distributions
in this form right and
any distribution that can be represented
in this form
belongs to the exponential family the
only constraint is that
is that the choices of b t
and a should be such that the this whole
term is always non-negative and
integrates to 1 when you integrate out y
subject to those constraints for any
choice of
b t and a you have
a distribution in the exponential family
right
now any any questions before we see how
the uh gaussian and and bernoulli belong
to this family any any questions with
with this so far
yes question go ahead
what is that symbol uh at the bottom
this one oh just a capital a i just
called it some you know capital a of eta
and use log capital a
this question
oh so question is why are we dividing by
the uh um
the expectation so we divided by the
integral of of the numerator with
respect to y which will
make it normalized to 1.
so so think of it as so you have
some a set of numbers 1 5
7 and you want to maintain their ratios
but still make them
add up to 1. so you divided by 1 plus 5
plus 7 1 plus 5 plus 7
1 plus 5 plus 7 right
and this makes them normalized into a
probability
uh distribution they sum up to one now
so
and and here we are doing the same thing
for
in in a continuous scale right so
integrate out
the numerator and and divided by the
that integral so this this is called
normalization
so you think of one plus five plus seven
as the
the different values this evaluates to
for different values of y
right
all right so um uh maybe to to uh answer
this
uh uh theorem so let's see what happens
here
now ah we have some function b of
ah call it b prime of y
times e of eta times y
now let us assume this
p of y equals this and let's assume the
integral of
p of y is equal to integral of
b prime of y times e of the eta times
y is equal to some k let's say equal to
right but now we want we want this
to be a valid probability distribution
which means
when you integrate out y we want it to
be equal to 1
right so what you do is you want to
divide it by 100
so that when you integrate the whole
thing you get one
right and and this 100 comes because
that's what you got by integrating it
out in the first place
so so the ah
so the integral of b prime of
y times exponent of um
a times why integral
of
right now
this term this the the entire
denominator is just a
constant and this will be equal to one
over integral of
b prime of y x eta dot y times
the numerator is integral of
theta y and you just cancel them and
equal to one
right that you know that's you're just
you're just normalizing it
such that the integral is always one
that makes sense
yeah so this is just this is this is the
process of what you call as an
exponential tilting
and uh there are there are uh good
reasons why you want to tilt something
using the exponent function there are uh
there's a lot of theory of why
the exponent is is the right choice to
do right it's it's you know um think of
that as beyond the scope of this class
yes questions
uh so here you know uh just to give the
intuition we are considering eta to be a
scalar in this case
so yeah if this was a vector then sure
you know think of this as
and then the integral would be you know
you would be integrating over y 1
d y 2 etcetera
yes question
the very first line so uh
so this is this is the assumption we are
making uh
you know where taking a base measure b
prime of y
we want to construct a new measure such
that the new measure is proportional to
b prime of y times exponent of some
parameter times y
so the the intuition is that you're just
defining a new distribution
which is defined like this right and
this is called
you know the tilted distribution the
exponentially tilted distribution
okay but the the the main point here is
that
you know we went through this just to
get and get a flavor of why the names
came into
picture right and and we can we can go
into details after the class you know
come up to the come up to the stage we
can
can go into the details but the main
point is that
if you can decompose a probability
density
into this form into these components
then you know
that distribution belongs to the
exponential family
right now let us look at a few
distributions which
which actually follow this
pattern
so let us start with the bernoulli
distribution
so the bernoulli distribution p of y
parameterized by
phi is written as
phi to the y times 1 minus
phi to the 1 minus y
right this is the bernoulli distribution
and the claim is that this
this this form of of the bernoulli
distribution
can be rewritten in the exponential
family form right how do we do that
so um the first thing
we can think of is we can take
the exponent of the log
of v to the y
1 minus v to the 1 minus y
right just took the exponent and the log
that um
and the reason why we can take the log
is because this is positive and this is
positive so
you can take the log and then you know
take the exponent again
right and now we can rewrite this as
exponent
so this will be y log
phi plus 1 minus y
log 1 minus v
and this rearranging terms again
exponent
so i'm going to collect terms that have
y in them to the left
and to the right are terms that do not
have y
so we will get
log phi over 1 minus
v times y
plus log
1 minus v
so all we have done here is pure
algebraic manipulation right we started
with this form
and brought it to this form and now we
can see
um you know start doing a pattern
matching right so the
exponential families as p of y given
eta is equal to b of
y times exponent
eta transpose y minus
a of eta right
now we want to patent match these two so
ah
first thing we notice is that you know
this is eta so eta
equals log
phi over one minus v
and this implies
if we invert this we get
v equals one over one plus e to the
minus eta
and surprisingly and and
not coincidentally this is the logistic
function
and ah moving on so
ah so we have eta equals this and phi
equals this
and t of y equals
t of y is just y in this case
so this should be sorry t of y t of y is
just y
and a of eta
so a of eta is equal to
minus because a has a negative sign
minus
log 1 minus phi
and if you plug in phi from this
expression
a of eta will end up being log
of 1 plus e to the eta
and b of y
is just one
right so we started with the bernoulli
distribution
i did a whole bunch of just pure
algebraic manipulation
you know nothing more than algebraic
manipulation we didn't use any kind of
you know logical reductions or anything
anything like that
and just kind of massaged it into this
form
and did a pattern match to extract the
corresponding
b function sufficient statistic log
partition function
and and
and eta and eta over here
ah forgot to mention eta is called the
natural parameter
right so yeah so
start with the the density function
massage it into this form and using
pattern matching just
extract out the relevant relevant
terms of the exponential family and so
we have shown
that the bernoulli distribution belongs
to the exponential family
right that's what we what that's what
which we showed that bernoulli
distribution belongs to the exponential
family yes question
so the question is how does this fee
relate to the
the g function that we saw in in
logistic uh
regression you know last class right um
uh hold on a few more minutes you know
the the the uh relation will be become
clear
right now similarly let's repeat this
exercise for the gaussian distribution
right so the gaussian distribution has
the form
p of y given mu comma
sigma square now we are just considering
the
univariate gaussian not the multivariate
and
this will be 1 over square root of 2
pi times sigma
exponent of minus half
y minus mu square by
sigma square right this is the the uh
standard gaussian distribution in our
case
we will be assuming a constant variance
and for the sake of derivation we're
just going to assume
sigma square equals 1. you can leave it
sigma square as some constant
sigma square itself and we will get the
same results but
you know the derivations will look a
little more complex
oh yes question
how come the transpose and the eight are
disappeared good question thank you
so uh in this case uh eight is just a
scalar
so uh yeah when you have two scalars
transposing them will is
is uh uh is the same as just leaving it
as it is yeah
right so here we're going to assume
sigma square equals 1
which gives us a simplified version of
the gaussian here
mu is equal to 1 over square root
2 pi exponent
of minus half y minus
mu square
and this we can see is you know
expand the square and get 1 over
square root 2 pi
exponent of minus
half y square
times
exponent mu y
minus half mu square
right so what happened here basically
expanded the square
and one of the terms will have will be
will have only y's
so got that out and uh the other two
the two terms are here um yeah
and with this we can again now do uh
you know the same pattern matching
exercise t of y
eta equals b of y
exponent eta transpose
t of y minus a f
eta and
doing this pattern pattern matching we
see that
eta equals mu in this case
beta equals mu and similarly
mu equals eta
the sufficient statistic t of y is just
equal to y
ok a of eta
equals mu square over 2
and that is the same as eta square over
right and finally b
of y equals
1 over
2 pi exponent
of minus y squared by 2.
right any questions in this uh
you can assume sigma squared to be uh
some constant
and uh you know this is going to uh have
a few sigma squares in a few places but
you know it's just a constant
uh and and as far as you know
constructing uh
generalized linear models is concerned
you know that has no bearing so
we're just gonna you know just to make
just to make the the algebra simple
you're gonna assume uh
sigma square equals one and that's
completely harmless
any questions in this right so ah and
and and
here we can see that um
from the the ah
point of view of exponential tilting it
it kind of suggests that you get the
bernoulli if you
start with a uniform distribution and
perform an exponential tilting
and over here we actually see that for
the gaussian distribution
this is actually a standard normal
distribution that has a
mean zero standard deviation one and
it's still a gaussian distribution
right so for the gaussian distribution
if you perform an exponential tilting
then you still get a gaussian
distribution which is you know different
different parameters anyway that's just
ah
you know let's just tie it back to
the the uh the tilting interpretation
that we spoke about now
exponential families have a few
nice properties
properties of
exponential families
one property is that
log p of y
eta
is
concave in eta that is
mle is
concave which is the same as
the loss function negative log
likelihood
is convex
n eta in eight
right another property
is that the
expectation of y
data equal to
so the first derivative of the log
partition function is the expectation of
the distribution
right this might look a little you know
why is this the case
similarly the variance
of y
is the second derivative of
the log partition function
and this might look a little
ah surprising initially but it should
not be
so surprising when we see the fact that
the log partition function came from the
moment generating function right and the
moment generating function as the
properties that
as you keep taking derivatives it keeps
generating the moments of the
distribution
right so the ah the first derivative of
the log partition function which is also
the log
moment generating function gives the
first moment the second derivative gives
you the second moment and so on yes
question
um good question
what i was about to gonna say is that
you have these three questions as your
homework question
so i'm not going to uh reveal a lot
about that and
and i think you know question number
four and in your homework one is is
you're asked to prove
exactly this um
yeah so these are these are some very
nice properties about
the exponential family and
they're especially nice because in
general if you're given a distribution
and asked to calculate the expectation
you are required to take the integral of
something right you are expect to take
the integral of
your your variable um um with
multiplied by the density and if you
want to take the uh
calculate the variance you you know
you're supposed to take the integral of
the squared
square of the variable with respect to
the density um
and and you know in general performing
integration is hard it's it's it's messy
it's not nice
right but but for the exponential family
uh instead of doing integration you can
actually
you know just differentiate the log
partition function and you take you
differentiate it twice you get the
second moment
those are you know these are some nice
properties about um
the log partition about exponential
families any questions
yes question
is this obvious or is there a proof it
is
i mean there is a proof and you know
your homework question number four
homework one is you're asked to prove
this
why is it concave i mean it's uh it's
it's it's in your homework you need to
show it
yeah all these are in your home
oh nll is negative log likelihood
um so the maximum likelihood estimate
um is uh to calculate the maximum
likelihood estimate
you take the probability you know or the
log of the probability
and you maximize this with respect to
eta now if you just switch the sign you
get the negative of this
and that's generally considered as the
last function which you want to minimize
so you know if in the maximum likelihood
interpretation you're trying to maximize
something and um you know from a loss
function perspective you want to
minimize
something so you just flip the sign and
you know it and that's generally
considered the loss function
next question
what's uh can can you please explain
what's concave down and
concave up
oh okay oh i see i see i see so so the
question is by concave
uh do i mean this or do i mean this
right is
is the function shaped like this or the
function shape like this
so the common nomenclature is
when you have a global maxima when
there's a maxima
you call it concave and when there is a
global minima you call it convex
okay so if you have a convex function
the negative of that will be
a concave function and vice versa good
question
any other questions all right so
that's that's you know that's that's it
about exponential families and now we're
going to see how
the exponential family kind of ties into
uh generalized linear models
okay
right so generalized linear maps
so with the exponential families so far
we were dealing with y right the
variable y so we were defining
um a probability distribution over y
and the parameter was eta right and
there was no x anywhere right in in
supervised learning we are trying to
learn a mapping from x to y
right so in generalized linear models we
we now use the exponential family to
introduce a relation between
a set of variables x to the variable y
and how do we do that we make the
following
three assumptions or or uh
these are like the the the the three the
three steps for
constructing a glm so first
is we make the assumption y given x
belongs to exponential family
respect to eta right
that is given x and sum theta
y now belongs to some exponential family
whose parameter is eta
right so far
so far in this lecture we assumed we
were or
we didn't assume but we were considering
the cases when y belong
to exponential family
parameter eta but now we say
y given x belongs to an exponential
family with parameter
eta and
our the goal of prediction
will be to predict the mean
so the hypothesis that we want to learn
is the expectation of y
given x
and the third
assumption that we are going to make is
now connecting
x theta and eta so
here we are going to make a reasonably
strong assumption
that eta will be equal to theta
transpose x
right so these two seem somewhat
reasonable
ah you know we're just assuming y given
x follows some
exponential family distribution and also
uh
the second assumption was that the
hypothesis or the the value that we want
to predict
for an input x is going to be the
expectation of this distribution if you
know
in general when you when you know um
that a variable is distributed according
to some distribution
and you're asked to make a prediction of
what value is you know predicting the
mean of the distribution is a pretty
reasonable
you know pretty reasonable value to
predict so this seems pretty reasonable
and then we make yet another assumption
of the way we
tie the parameter of the exponential
family with the inputs
as eta equals theta transpose x
right now together with these three uh
assumptions we can or are these three
steps we can construct
exponential family or generalized linear
models for
different exponential family
distributions
now let's see what happens ah how do we
construct
kind of in a in a pictorial way let's
the
these three assumptions or these three
steps can be kind of visualized like
this so
we have some x i
going to r d right
now i am going to run it through
like theta i am going to theta transpose
x i and that is going to output
data i right and this eta i
becomes the parameter of some
exponential family that has
you know some particular you know
sufficient statistic
log partition function b
of y by by choosing the three different
functions of an exponential family you
know you completely determine the
exponential family
and the output of of of
um the dot product between theta and
x become the natural parameter
of that exponential family and from this
we
sample y i right this is the big picture
you want to have in your mind okay
so next question
so the question is uh shouldn't
shouldn't
these functions also be somewhat uh
parameterized by the model
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i would i would um
the general process of how you go about
constructing a glm
is to first choose a distribution for
example
choose that you want to model your
output as gaussian or choose that you
want to
model your output as a poisson
distribution or choose that you want to
model your output as bernoulli
and by making that initial choice of
what distribution you want to use these
get fixed
right so these get fixed the you know
the t function a function and b function
they get fixed up front when we make
the choice of the distribution for y
right and then the question becomes what
is going to be the parameter
for a particular y i right and the
parameter the natural parameter
is then assumed to be ah
theta transpose x for a given example so
theta transpose x will give you
the natural parameter and from this y i
is
is obtained so this is the assumption
that we're going to make of how
our data was generated
right any questions about this
and
so think of this as just like as like
the flow chart of the data generating
process
of how we believe ah um
the data is generated a few things to
note here is that
theta is
global in the sense that you have just
one theta for
you know for for for the for the full
model but whereas the
parameter of the exponential family eta
is different for each example so each
example
each x will output a particular
natural parameter of the exponential
family
right
now we can now see how this relates to
for example linear regression right
so ordinary least squares or
linear regression
this question
uh what's the question why is theta
local to one family
no eta so um the uh
the question is why is eta local to one
family so the
um the exponential family uh corresponds
to distributions that have this
form right
right now once you choose
t a and b you fix the functional form of
your
exponential family and by for example by
choosing
your b t and a according to
uh you know that set of choices you get
the gaussian
by choosing b tna according to this set
of choices you get a bernoulli
so uh now if if if i understood uh you
correctly
uh the question is theta is is local to
x
is because
yes
i i i'm kind of uh trying to understand
what you mean by local to your data or
local to your
distribution
yeah so eta is you get a different data
for different examples so each
example will output its own eta
right so in this process x i uh take a
dot product with theta will give you eta
i
of the ith example
yes question
exactly exactly we will uh i'm going to
draw a picture about about that
in uh shortly right so um
so for the ordinary least squares if we
make the choice
that our exponential family is gaussian
then a natural consequence of that is
so if if you construct a generalized
linear family where the exponential
family
uh distribution is gaussian then you
naturally get
least squares regression is what you
should be doing right why is that
um so
assuming exponential
[Music]
family is
gaussian we get
h theta of x we want h theta of
x to be the expectation expectation of
y given x
and we saw that the mean of
of a gaussian is just mu
right mean of a gaussian is mu and mu as
a function of
eta was just eta
right and eta is equal to theta
transpose x
so we basically get h theta of x equals
theta transpose x
and that was our hypothesis for for ah
linear regression
similarly for ah logistic regression
so so logistic regression is again
basically a generalized linear model
where we choose the exponential family
to be bernoullis right but by just
making the choice that
the exponential family is bernoulli
logistic regression pops out as a
natural consequence
so um
again so assume exponential
family is bernoulli
h theta of x again is it should be
expectation of
y given x by theta
and in case of bernoulli the the mean of
the bernoulli was
is is just phi
right and phi as a function of
eta what we saw was is equal to
1 over 1 plus e to the minus eta
and then we make uh the third assumption
about
glms was that eta equals theta transpose
x so 1 over
1 plus e to the minus theta transpose x
h theta of x equals
equals this right and
and what we see here is that this is
exactly equal to
g of theta transpose x
where g of z equals 1
over 1 plus e to the minus z when we
introduce logistic regression
we arbitrarily chose g to take this form
something that's
that squishes minus infinity to plus
infinity into the range 0 to 1.
but this is a more principled way of
deriving it
where you think of your output to be
following following a bernoulli
distribution
and construct a glm and
with just those two assumptions we see
that
our hypotheses must take this form
yes question
was there a mathematical reason for our
third assumption so
this is a modeling choice uh where
you're you're making an assumption that
the natural parameter is
is um a linear combination of
of of your x's you can
make this relation as complex as
possible in general
right you know beyond glm's you can you
can for example say your
eta equals um you know
some neural network parameterized by
some some
some theta of your x right and this is
totally fine you can construct
um generalized models except now it's no
more linear you can't call it glm but
you know
you you can absolutely do something like
this
but for glms it's a linear model because
we are
making the assumption that eta is a
linear
function of xs
so the question is um
glms are convex or concave and when you
look at your scatter plot of your data
if it does not look
convex or concave should be still fit
glms to that data
right one thing to to note is that
um the glms and exponential families
are all convex or concave with respect
to the parameters and in a scatter plot
you're looking at data right you look
you know
there are two different things right now
your data
is generally kind of embedded in your
loss function in some way
it's kind of you know the shape of the
loss function is decided by your data
and the the shape of the loss function
is going to be very very different from
looking at the scatter plot of the data
itself right your your data may look
will may look in any shape or form right
but
that tells you nothing about how the
shape of the loss function is going to
look
so uh maybe this the next next uh
diagram i'm about to draw might
answer your question if not you know
please ask the question again
yeah so
what we what so uh here we see that
the the linear regression and
logistic regression pop out as natural
consequences
by just choosing by just making the
choice of our exponential family
distribution
right and now how does this kind of
look visually
so for linear regression um
ok so for linear regression assume this
to be
x axis the data right
and there is some theta that
so x is in r d theta is in
rd but for this picture we are just
assuming it is one dimensional
and here this line for example
this line is basically eta equals
theta transpose x for some theta
right and then what we what we saw was
eta for in case of the gaussian
distribution
is also equal to mu
right for the gaussian distribution eta
equals mu
and y for a given x is now distributed
as a gaussian
with mean mu so if we take the example
x i we get a mu i which means
for this value of x we assume that
centered around here we have a gaussian
distribution
right so this is y
and this is x i
and from this gaussian distribution we
sample a y
let us say we got this one and this is
y i similarly for a different say x j
there is a gaussian distribution and
from this gaussian distribution we
sample
lets say this is
y j
right so for every different value of
input
for every input value for every x
we dot it with theta we get eta
and that eta is equal to mu of a
gaussian distribution
centered at that centered at that at
that eta or mu and from that gaussian
distribution
you know it's it's a distribution along
this axis we sample a y
right and that makes the x x i y i pair
or the x j y j pair
right so let's look at a few more
there is another gaussian distribution
here
for this point
this at this point
this right and from this
we assume that the data is generated
this way
from this we get
this is x this is y
so i am just going to try to draw those
points again
right so this x this is y the data was
generated so this is the
data generation process
and now when we start our machine
learning analysis we start from here
right this is the observation or the
data
right and from this observation we now
want to infer
what theta is
right so each point over here
has you know ah so so the true theta
might
might be something like this but we do
not know
each example each wire high
has two parts right so
each of these is is basically
theta transpose x plus epsilon where
epsilon
is the gaussian noise so theta transpose
x you know think of this as the signal
and you have a noise
and you're trying to separate the signal
from the noise right we want to get
what the signal is what is theta what is
the the invisible dotted line over here
from which the ys are sampled right
and the way this relates to generalized
linear models is that
we assume for each example there is an
exponential family distribution
in this case the gaussian for each
example
there is a gaussian distribution and the
y was sampled from the gaussian
distribution
right and now by just by just starting
with ah
the x and y pairs without seeing
anything else
we want to we want to learn what what
what theta is
and and that's where you know that's
basically statistics machine learning
where you start from the data and you're
trying to
construct what the modulus yes questions
so the question is in practice how do we
know whether
you know the noise actually follows a
gaussian distribution or not right
and uh the the short answer to that is
it might sound funny but in machine
learning we don't care but in statistics
you care a lot
because in in machine learning our our
goal
is um are we able to learn a model
that you know that just you know does
well in terms of prediction on unseen
data
right whereas in in in classical
statistics uh
we are trying to your data is is kind of
you know hopefully generated with a
well-designed experiment where if you
perform a regression analysis
the values of you know theta are
meaningful in some way you can test a
hypothesis right and
and over there the you know the the
assumption of whether
the noise was actually gaussian or not
are very important
right but from machine learning point of
view we are mostly interested in
how well our model predicts on unseen
data for example for example if
um y i is you know if if there is a new
test example x star
our model you know suppose it it
learned this other line to be the uh
to be the hypothesis then it's going to
say this is you know
going to be your prediction and the uh
um
yeah so in general we are we are
interested in you know what is this
gap basically right and and in practice
it's not even possible to
measure this gap because we don't know
the first dotted line
so um so we're going to make this
prediction but
the true data was sampled from you know
from from a distribution centered on the
first dotted line so your data might be
here and what we care is
how far was our prediction from you know
the observed data and that's all is
our focus in machine learning we are not
trying to we care less about
you know what was the specific value of
theta is it meaningful you know
those are questions that's more
classically handled by statistics and
not machine learning good questions
right so so uh i guess to summarize your
question you know is there is there a
more principled way of
of choosing what our distribution should
be
right um the the uh short answer there
is
you know um so in machine learning
when we are given a set of data right
let's assume you have some training set
right generally what we do is we we
split it into a training set
and a validation set and a test set
right and for for
you know uh questions such such as the
one you posed about you know what's the
choice of
you know the exponential family
distribution we want to make the answer
almost always is going to be you know
try both approaches try try two
different distributions say gaussian and
laplace
and see how well that performs on the
validation test
on the validation set and whichever of
the choices work better on your
validation set go with that
yes that's just the limitation that we
live with yeah exactly
yes questions
well so the question is here we are
sampling why
um the sampling is the assumption that
we are making of
how the data was generated under the
covers
so what we are predicting
is so with with so with linear
regression
we saw two different interpretations
right one was just minimize the cost
function
take the data that we have minimize the
cost function the other was the uh the
probabilistic interpretation right
and right there we had made the
assumption that your y
i was sampled from a normal distribution
whose mean was theta transpose x
right and we are making that assumption
which may or may not be
true and if we believe in that
assumption
then the maximum likelihood principle
tells us that we need to minimize the
squared loss
right and similarly over here um
if we make or generalize if we assume
that our data is from a generalized
linear model
where the exponential family is is is
gaussian
then our hypothesis should be you know
maybe a a raised our hypothesis should
be just theta transpose x you know which
is
basically the linear
linear regression hypothesis and if you
perform maximum likelihood expectation
on your
generalized linear model then you get
the squared loss as well
right so these the linear regression and
logistic regression
are exactly specific cases
of generalized linear models where
we chose the family exactly by making a
choice of the family
uh to be gaussian we get exactly linear
regression by making a choice to be
bernoulli we get exactly logistic
regression
right so that's that's you know this is
the picture you want to have
in mind for a linear regression
that the assumption is that there is
there is some
theta some true theta
which acts as the mean for each
y i that we are going to sample from and
the y
eyes that we are going to observe are
going to be sampled from this so there
are some noise coming in
and we start with these noisy
observations and we're
you know the the the hope is that we
kind of
you know prune away the noise and can
extract the signal in there right that's
that's that's the picture you want to
have and similarly for
logistic regression
yes question
so we don't get a theta we when you when
you start your machine learning task
you're just giving your data set your
x's and y's
right and then we make an assumption
that the way
the the uh data was generated was
you know through a generalized linear
model if we
make that assumption then the you know
the set of actions we need to take is to
perform maximum likelihood on a
generalized linear model
which which uh and if the generalized
linear model has a gaussian distribution
then you get linear regression
we don't generate wise we we we just we
just take the observed x's and y's and
and start from there exactly we don't we
don't sample
we don't know any kind of sampling as
part of our analysis
i'm sorry can you please repeat that
so what we um effectively what we are
doing is we are trying to
estimate what theta hat is we try to
come up with an estimate theta hack
that is as close as possible to the true
theta that is essentially what we are
trying to do right the output of our
model
is always some parameter vector theta
like for example you know you do linear
regression say use the normal equations
the output of the normal equation is
some theta hat
and that is our estimate of what the
slope was
so for logistic regression the picture
looks
again somewhat similar so this is x
and assume
this is eta equals theta transpose x
right and now we have yet another
function
which is the activation function
oops i messed this up sorry
this is y equals zero and
y equals 1 right so for the logistic
regression again
um this is
phi equals awesome
equals g of
eta equals 1
right again for logistic regression you
know assume x is our day
x is our our data axis
for simplicity uh we're just drawing it
as one dimensional but in general this
is
in d dimensional right and
eta equals theta transpose x is this you
know
hyperplane or you know a line in one
dimension
right and what we then have in case of
linear regression
eta was mu but in case of logistic
regression
phi that is you know the mean is not
equal to eta but g of eta where
you know it takes this form now this is
basically our our logistic regression
hypothesis
right this is also h theta of x for
relationship
and now the the um
the way the we the the way the data is
generated
the way you want to think about it is
that for any given value of x
right calculate ah g of eta
this is the phi or vi corresponding to x
i
and from this vi
sample of y right now if
if it is close to one if if the mean of
the bernoulli is close to one then it is
more likely that you are going to sample
a one instead of a zero so
for example here we might get here and
for this again
you might get here this might you know
here here maybe you know one of them
might be here
and similarly for for for
low probabilities for those regions of x
where
the g theta of x will be a low
probability you're mostly going to get
things here and maybe occasionally one
of them will be here
and for the region where your your
h theta of x is close to point five you
would expect
you know roughly
an equal number to be you know both up
and down
right and from this data generation
process
we get a data set that might look like
this x
and y so
right so you might get a data set that
looks like this
again this just visualize in one
dimension um
and from this we want to now work
backwards towards
you know the theta that gave rise to
you know the the hyperplane which then
gave
gave rise to this logistic function from
which the data was in
a sample
right does that make sense
from here we want to then backwards and
ask
what was theta
so there are any questions on this
yes
so in um i said um
in case of linear regression eta equals
mu
precisely because we made the gaussian
assumption
right so a few things to kind of ah
keep in mind there are lots of
parameters moving around here right so
we have eta we have muse we have fees we
have thetas
and it's you know
it's quite easy to kind of get lost in
all these different parameters
and and so it's it's it can be useful to
have a big picture of where the
different parameters
uh kind of lie and what role they play
and what is their relationship with each
other
so
we have model parameters
then we have the natural parameter
then we have
right so theta
in r d
is the model parameter
eta i um is the natural parameter
and the mean parameter is going to be
different for distributive distributions
for example if it is mu
for
gaussian fee for
bernoulli lambda for
[Music]
poisson
you know and whatever it could be
and
the choice of the distribution
implicitly chooses which mean parameter
we are working with
right and the relation between the model
parameters
which must the the dimension must match
with
x
the model parameters dotted with x give
the natural parameters right
so we have theta transpose
x i gives the natural parameters so that
is the relation between
your model parameters and the natural
parameters the natural parameters is one
for example
right and then from the natural
parameter to
the mean parameters we have something
called
the g function so the g function takes
us from
natural parameter to the mean parameter
in case of gaussian
g equals you know just you know
g of
in case of gaussian g
of eta is just equal to eta
and and similarly in case of you know
bernoulli phi equals g
of eta equals 1 over 1 plus e to the
minus eta
and so on right and this function
the the the function g that takes you
from the natural parameter to the
mean of the distribution is generally
called the canonical response function
and the canonical response function has
this
property that it will always have an
inverse right it is always an invertible
function
and the inverse which takes you from the
mean back to the natural parameter is
generally called the
canonical link function
instantly called the canonical response
function because ah generally
y is also called the response variable
sometimes
and so it is taking you from etas to
like the mean of your y so it's it's
also called the canonical response
function
and the canonical link function is is
basically the
inverse of it and uh the thing you want
to keep in mind
is you know
that there are three different kinds of
parameters we can talk about
the first is the thetas and when you
perform
gradient ascend to perform maximum
likelihood on your gaussian
or on your generalized linear models
these are the parameters that get
trained
right these are the parameters that we
are adjusting in each step of gradient
descent or stochastic gradient descent
right and once you fix these the natural
parameters are just the output
of theta transpose x for different
values of x's so you
these are kind of ephemeral in some way
they you know the we don't store them
whereas
you know we train and store the uh theta
parameters
right and the natural parameters are
just the output
for different values of inputs right and
then you take them
through the the canonical response
function and you get the mean of your
you know y variables and this is the
prediction that we do right
so the prediction is is uh
is h
theta of x equal to the expectation
of y given x
theta and this is always g of
theta transpose x
yeah so are there other kinds of
generalized linear models ah that's the
next
thing we're going to discuss
right so
so we saw two examples
for generalized linear models
classification and regression
and let us see if let's see a few other
types of glms
so in order to first construct the glm
right
in order to first construct a glm the
first thing that we do is first look at
our data
right you have you are given pairs of x
and y's
the first thing you want to do is look
at your y and find out
what data type it is right your y
variable might be
binary just zeros and ones it can be
real valued
which means it can take a value between
minus infinity and plus infinity
it can be counts which means it exists
only as integers
you know like counts of how many clicks
that is my website going to have or
count of number customers who are going
to walk in through the door it could be
just counts
it could be it could be
multi-class discrete and in the sense if
you're trying to
if you're trying to perform
classification of whether a given
given um uh image is i don't know a cat
or a dog or an elephant right it can be
discreet but and not binary but a set of
set of classes
right and it can also be just positive
real value for example you know
you um if the y value is
the time until some event happens then
it's real valued but just limited to
positive values
right so the first thing that you want
to do is look at the data type of y
right and supposing the data type of y
is r real valued then
then the next thing you want to do is
make a choice about which exponential
family
distribution you want to use that has a
support
compatible with your data type right for
example
if if if it is real value from minus
infinity to infinity
look up the table of exponential
families say on wikipedia wikipedia's
you know page of exponential families
gives you a table of all
uh exponential family distributions and
look at those
that have support equal to the full real
line
and those are all you know eligible
options for you right so for example you
can choose gaussian
or you can use a plus
right and
there may be a few more right ah but
they need to be limited to
the exponential family and when your
data type is
is real value then the thing that we the
name that we give it
is regression
ok similarly if it is
0 or 1 then
we choose bernoulli
and we call it classification
for the choice of gaussian we got linear
regression
as our algorithm for choice of laplace
you're going to get a different
algorithm but it's still a valid
algorithm
for bernoulli we got logistic regression
now it could be
1 through k
and here it can be categorical
distribution
and we call that multi-class
classification
if it is natural numbers or counts
then one example could be poisson
this is there in your homework so in
your homework question four or
question three or something um you're
going to construct
a generalized linear model for poisson
you know take a data set fit it make
predictions etc
and you call this you know either count
regression or
poisson regression
similarly if it is
positive real values and specifically if
it is like
if your y variable is time to some event
then
you have choices like um exponential
so the exponential distribution is
distinct from exponential family
the exponential distribution is a member
of the exponential family
it may be confusing but now this is the
exponential distribution not the
exponential family
exponential or you can use gamma
distribution there are a few more and
generally when you are
trying to predict the time to some event
you call it survival analysis
right and you can also have
your data type to be probability
distributions themselves
so this may be a little little
advanced but if you are doing bayen
statistics for example
you can define a probability
distribution over bernoulli
distributions
in which case the exponential family for
bernoulli uh would be a beta
distribution
and you can give it some name similarly
um you know your
your um your y variable can be a
categorical distribution itself in which
case
you know you want to have a distribution
over distributions like for example the
dirichlet distribution
and all of these can be fit in to the
generalized linear model framework
right you start with what your y
variable is data type of
y and
the data type of y is going to inform
the choice of distributions that you can
use
right so if somebody you know if if you
are wondering is generalized
linear models used for regression or for
classification the answer is
it can be used for anything just use the
appropriate choice of
exponential family distribution
right a question yes
i'm not going to go deep into that you
can you can ask me after the lecture i
can
um i can explain more
any any any questions
no what was the what what did we gain by
putting them all in a common framework
right we saw that you know um yes you
know uh
it's kind of mathematically elegant to
kind of put them all into a common
framework but
but have we gained anything as such
right the answer is yes we have actually
gained
once we make a choice of distribution
we can go through the exercise of you
know algebraically
massaging it and doing a pattern
matching to find out
what our g function is
so first thing you want to do is
make a choice of distribution
according to the data type
right
now and for that distribution
express it in exponential family
exponential family which means you know
find out what is a
what is you know a of eta b of y
t of y um and most importantly
your mu or phi or the the mean parameter
you know express it as a function of
eta right so calculate the g function
right that's that's the most crucial
part right
and this g function will decide what
your hypothesis is so
the hypothesis h
theta of x is now
g of theta transpose x
right
and probably the most
the most useful benefit of going through
of building a glm is that
once you do this in order to perform
maximum likelihood
estimation you don't really need to
write out the log probability take the
gradient
you know and and and um derive an update
rule
the update rule for all generalized
linear models
is the same rule and that that rule is
theta
equals theta plus some step size alpha
times y i minus h
theta of x i times
x i right we've seen this update rule
over and over
and what you can see is if you start
for any generalized linear model for any
choice of
the distribution you take the log
probability
perform maximum likelihood estimation to
get the gradient and
the update rule that you end up with
will always take this form
right so in case of logistic regression
your y i's are zeros and ones
your h theta is you know goes according
to this
and for linear regression your y's could
be could be you know
a real value for poisson regression
they're going to be counts but no matter
what data type you have
the update rule that you're going to end
up with is always the same
just that h theta of x will be different
according to
the choice of g right and finally for
prediction
right prediction y hat is always
h theta of x star and this again is
equal to
g of theta transpose
x star right so basically by
by uh with glms not only
do we have a nice and elegant unifying
theory
but it also gives you an update rule
that you can go directly
without writing out the log likelihood
without taking the gradients
you know you can just go and start using
this update rule
and you know and run it till your model
converges
yes question
that's a very good point so the question
is when we use this y hat
um according to this then our our our
prediction that we are making
will not lie in the support of the data
type right that that is all
that is true um and for example for
logistic regression the the hypothesis
will output a probability value
right and then it is up to us to choose
some kind of a threshold
to say you know anything above this
threshold we classify it as
as as um as positive and anything below
you know we classified as negative and
similarly for
even for poisson regression right your
data types are going to be counts
but the value that comes out of this is
going to be real valued
right and again in which case you can
either round it to the minimum you know
to the nearest integer
or you can you know just sample from the
poisson you know that
you you can you can do something like
that exactly yes question
[Music]
um
this was just x star just to say some
test example you know
some unseen example
so um yes questions
so the question is uh the the threshold
that we want to choose to decide whether
the output of a logistic regression was
one or zero can we adjust that threshold
yes you can adjust that threshold it's
it's it's generally you know um it's
generally a post-processing step which
means you you fit the model as it is
and after you fit the model you know on
a validation set you can decide what
threshold you actually want to use you
don't always have to use point
five you can use a different threshold
it's generally not something that you
learn from the training data so the
threshold is not something that you
learn from your training data the
threshold is something that you tune
on a validation set and we will probably
cover uh we're going to have a lecture
on evaluation metrics in you know in one
of the
future lectures and there we we're going
to talk about thresholds and and things
like that
all right so moving on um
the last topic um i want to cover today
is
a soft max regression
right soft max regression so softmax
regression is
again a type of it it is part of the
exponential family
um or a generalized linear model when
you make a choice of
you know categorical as your as
your choice of exponential family
you get multi-class classification and
this is also called soft max regression
so ah the lecture notes has uh you know
a pretty detailed
uh uh it walks you step by step
of how you actually construct uh softmax
regression as a generalized linear model
and a higher encourage you you know you
need to kind of go through that in the
lecture notes
um to to kind of you know go through the
mechanics of it
uh but in uh but during the lecture
instead um
i want to provide some kind of uh um
some intuitions about how soft max
regression works so that
what you read in the lecture notes you
know which is pretty heavy on notation
um so that it makes a little more sense
right
so soft max regression is for
multi-class classification
and lets start with some pictures
right in case of ah
x one x d
in case of logistic regression um
we started off with two classes
let's say this is class one and then we
have
another class over here
um
these are some examples right um
in the the picture we drew for the
generalized linear model
we just had one one dimension for the x
axis
and y was on the other dimension over
here
um this is x one and x x d
and the y or the label is basically you
know embedded in in the shape or the
color over here right
and then um our our goal
was to come up with some theta
such that theta transpose
theta transpose x equal to 0
this line would act as a
separating hyperplane right that was
that was
a logistic regression and
theta transpose x greater than 0
was like the positive classes and theta
transpose x less than 0 was the
negative classes this assumes that you
know
p of y given x theta
equals 0.5 is the separating hyperplane
so if you assume
you know 0.5 is is the separating
probability then
uh the theta that you learn um has this
property that it's it's a separating
hyperplane on one side
where it's greater than 0 you get you
classified as positive and the other
side is negative
right now what happens
in case of multi classes right what if
we have multiple classes
x1 xd
right let's assume um there are some
there's one class over here
and another class over here
some examples over here
and let's use another color and say
right and let us say these you know um
let's say this belongs to y equals 1
y equals 2 and similarly whatever y
equals k
right we have k different classes living
in a d dimensional
input space right and we want to now
build a multi class
classifier so
the first thing we want to
we want to change from this view is
first we want to figure out what
where is the theta vector right so in
this case the theta vector
will be like this right so this is the
theta vector
right because any vector which is less
than 90 degrees from theta will give you
a dot product that is positive
any any vector that is you know more
than 90 degree will give a dot product
that is negative right so this is our
theta vector
when we when we
move on to multi class classification
here we will now have one theta per
class
right so this i am going to call it
theta 2
um this would be
theta 1 and
let's call this
theta k so for every class you get your
own theta vector
right and over here it was it was clear
so
uh if theta transpose x was you know
bigger than zero it was one class it was
less than zero there are other class but
now we have
you know multiple theta vectors and
the way we're going to um classify
something
as belonging to one class is to take
that input vector
x right calculate
theta one
transpose x calculate theta
transpose x and so on until
theta k transpose x
right each is a scalar
and pick the
pick the corresponding k for which the
theta k transpose x
is the largest
right so each of this is in r right
and from this what we want to do is to
take the max
or rather the arg max
as the as the predicted class
the intuition to have there is that
for the set of examples
that belong to a class the
the theta k is is
is is kind of pointed in that direction
so that
only those examples belonging to the
class
will give a dot product with this vector
to be much larger than
their dot products with the other thetas
right for example for for you know pick
this
this blue right the dot product between
this example and theta k because they
are you know
um so well aligned is going to be much
bigger than
the dot product of this with say the red
because in fact this is greater than 90
degrees so this will be a negative value
and similarly the dot product between
this and the black vector will be
negative value but
between the blue vector it's going to be
positive and so you know
the class k will win out as the max
right and this set of thetas
we want to write it out in in a matrix
form
right where each each row is d
dimensional
and you multiply this with a vector x
which is also d dimensional
and this will give you um and you have k
such vectors right you have you have one
one
one uh theta vector specific to each
class
and you dot it you get a real value and
for some example let us call it x i
the different
theta transpose xs might look like this
so for i equals 0 for class 0
you might get theta transpose x for
class 1
the dot product might be negative for
class 2
again the dot product might be you know
positive
and the way soft max regression works is
to take the set of these
scalar valued dot products and convert
them into a probability distribution
right now given a set of scalar valued
um scalar valued numbers how do we now
convert this
into a probability distribution so for a
probability distribution there are
two properties the first thing is that
all the value should be non-negative and
the second property is that they should
sum over to one
right so the first thing we do is make
them all positive
while still maintaining the relative
orders
and how we how and can you suggest one
way how we can
how we can convert all of these into
positive values while
while still maintaining the relative
orders
you can add a constant very good another
way is to
i'm sorry you can the
absolute function will make it positive
but
they it might not maintain the order for
example a highly negative one
might become might might become larger
you can use the sigmoid function very
good the sigmoid function
will squash everything between 0 and 1.
a simple
simple technique is to just exponentiate
them
right so
exponentiate each
x i transpose
of theta i
and this will now make them all positive
so if if um
if the input to exponent is minus
infinity it maps it to zero
if it's highly negative it maps it to a
very small positive number
and if the value is positive it will
make it much much more positive
right and then we normalize it
we normalize it such that the heights
add up to one
right
and how do we normalize it
dividing it by the integral if this was
continuous
in case of discrete you we sum them up
and divide them right
and you get
i'm just going to continue it here so
you get
exponent of
x transpose theta
i over summation over
j exponent of x transpose
theta j and this will be
probability that y
equals i given x
theta and this function is called the
softmax function
right the softmax function takes a set
of scalars
real valued scalars and converts them
into a probability distribution
right where the the larger valued
scalars
will have a higher probability the
smaller value scalars will have
a smaller probability and they all add
up to one right that's the
softmax function right any questions yes
can i write a little bigger sure um
sorry about the writing so
maybe i'll just try to write it a little
more clearly here probability
y equals i given x
theta is equal to
exponent of x transpose
theta i divided by
the sum overall j exponent
of x transpose theta
j is that clear
right so this is this is basically the
softmax function and the
reason why it's called softmax function
is because um
if you are given a vector x and
[Music]
you want to find you want to extract the
maximum value
or of you know the maximum the largest
component of x
um one way to do it is to do
x transpose
soft max of x and it will give you
something that is similar to
the max
the largest component of x but and this
is differentiable you can do gradient
descent etcetera and
you know it's it's it's a differentiable
smooth way of extracting the maximum
value of
of maximum component of some x so that's
why it's called the soft max
all right that's that's about it uh in
terms of uh
generalizing your models this is the big
picture you want to have in your mind
and exponential family which we already
discussed and
and generalized media models take
exponential families and relate it to
some input x
with the assumption eta equals theta
transpose x that's the big picture
right thank you